you're watching swype coming up on the
show this week Angela's putting fitness
trackers to the test in the land of the
Midnight Sun exercise gets shocking when
I take on an electric work out and stay
tuned for some exergaming to our viewers
got the titles to keep you moving now
it's mid-january and we all know what
that means you've probably already given
up on your new year's resolution to get
fit well guess what we're not going to
let you because on this week's episode
we're going to show you the tech to help
you stick to your exercise goals I'll be
explaining my funny-looking suit shortly
but first angela has been putting
fitness tracker to the test while
running a polar night half marathon in
Norway over 1,000 runners from 35
countries descended on tromsø to take
part in a 13.1 mile race in extreme
conditions and I took on the challenge
armed with some of the latest fitness
trackers to see how the data collected
on my run compared
the wearable electronics industry is
worth an estimated 20 billion dollars or
nearly 14 billion pounds and with some
of the biggest names in tech cashing in
there's no shortage of new devices
competing to help you achieve your
fitness goals so for this run I've got
six fitness trackers and put to the test
specifically for a running activity
they've obviously got lots of different
functions they all track your sleep and
do all sort of different things but for
this one I've set them all justa
typically for a run so with me and
doesn't have a quick look here I've got
the misfit flash I've got the Fitbit
search I've got the latest garmin be
very smart head shower I've got the
latest jawbone up three I've got the
Microsoft band and the latest tomtom
cuddly spark music as well so thank you
so just to show you the Microsoft and
says the ruling for an hour and a half
iceberg 785 calories and my heart rate
hit 155 having look on the other rest
you can actually scroll through these
devices and see what miles Tony miles
dear Anne with your average paces you
can look at your heart rate and calorie
distant some time as well obviously the
misfit / don't have her built in this
day and neither does the jawbone up
three so i'll have to check that data
when i'm finished
Oh marissen complete so let's see what
the expert has to say about the data so
let's look at some of the stats that
these six devices captured on Angela's
half marathon in Norway if we start with
distance now it's worth pointing out
that the tomtom spark had to be synced
with a laptop and she tells me she
didn't have one so that captured data on
the day you couldn't then look at it
afterwards and it's also worth pointing
out the jawbone up is way over at
seventeen point seven eight miles here a
very good time if that was the case I
think the best one here obviously
clearly is the Fitbit surge it's just
over the 13.1 that's probably because
she meandered through the course
slightly it shows that it was very
accurate there's a reason they are the
market leader at the moment now if we go
on to calories the only interesting
point here is the misfit flash now this
probably didn't work out that Andrew was
running hadn't been told that she was
running and therefore his basically done
his best job possible but because their
risk-based it means as soon as you start
wailing your arms around it's going to
capture as many calories as possible but
if we look at heart rate it's a very
similar story from across all of them
misfit flash doesn't have a heart rate
monitor so it's not registering there
but otherwise it's given us best
accurate as sort of measurement as
possible if you wanted to get better
measurements you'd obviously we're a
dedicated heart rate monitor strap and
it kind of sums up what activities track
is all about at the moment it's not
necessary about improving your peak
performance on a half marathon for more
about tracking whether you're walking
enough during the day or sleeping or
what have you and that's kind of where
they're at so Angela did really put
these to the test probably more than
they were designed to do I may have put
the devices to the test but my
experiment was not scientific the
trackers offered a closed estimation of
my activity but the data also indicates
complete accuracy is still to be desired
Angela Barnes Sky News
coming up in a moment my body's in for a
shock Oh as I begin some electric muscle
stimulation training that's after a
round up of some of this week's tech
news we love innovation here on swype so
check out this alarm clock Matt ruggy
really makes sure you get out of bed
because you need to stand on it for at
least three seconds in order to stop the
alarm and you can program it with
positive affirmations to help put you in
the right mood to the project launched
on crowdfunding site Kickstarter a new
app designed to help stop you from
undermining yourself in emails has been
downloaded nearly a hundred thousand
times in around 140 countries since
launching last month the just not sorry
plugin underlines words and phrases that
could make you appear less confident
like just sorry and I think at the
moment the app works on gmail in chrome
a team in New Zealand have developed
headphones that sense what you're doing
and respond to your action so you can
stop or pause music by simply taking
them out you can use sensi buds on
Android and iOS the projects currently
raising money on IndieGoGo top here
girlfriend you got 10 seconds come stick
around for our games review we've got
the titles helping you to have fun and
get fit the same time you have
electrodes for the abdominals you have
electrodes for the back now remember
that electric workout i mentioned
earlier also you have quadriceps glutes
and hamstring electrodes in there so
we're going to directly stimulate them
all through the exercises well there you
go i life they'll be amplified by the
suit would be about 150 times harder
than what you normally would do 150
times exactly so it's gonna be these
whites here kind of feel like to be at
20 30 kilos after the world alright
let's try
oh that's really strong down around oh
good work really weird sense agent just
basic moves feel pretty tough when
you're being shocked at the same time
but isn't this route isn't as dangerous
for my nervous system no it's not then
mimics what happening hitch we haven't
seen in your system so what we're doing
we just spiked an apple system your
brains were you sending your muscles
between pulses so we're just really
mimicking what's happening in there if
your abs been worked you for your glutes
your hamstrings the whole time every
part of your body's getting worked over
euro incest anyone can have a go at this
kind of electric muscle stimulation
workout and they haven't been any
dangerous long-term effects see sure
though the researchers out there been a
long long time now and there's been
culled from the medical background and
from Vizio is your tens machines same
key co-workers will just push right
there we go you guys keep down pusher it
there we go well done now as you get
more advanced you just increase the
intensity the burns really kicking in
now but if you're short on time it's
this sort of Technology neuro reckons
you'll want to include in your exercise
regime what we do is a pull a
five-minute equivalent to an hour and a
half in the gym for more and more people
with the vision loss goals for these
kids that they have alternative
technology to get what they want
now look if throwing on electrode suits
or running marathons just isn't your
thing don't worry we've got plenty of
other options for you here's Chris with
a roundup of games to get you moving
fitness stuff I mean it's a new year
which means a lot of us are telling
ourselves that we're gonna start running
doing things and moving around which
clearly as you look at me I'm an expert
at so there's a lot of things out there
that are sort of games as well but can
get you fit it's called zombie run the
idea is you know let you get the 10k
like couch to think a kind of apps it's
one of those but you occasionally get
chased by zombies with this it's
dombey's are going to kill you which is
a pretty good incentive to move and it's
got a story well there's a little base
camp you've got the go to your
collecting things for the base camp if
there's always get you you lose all the
things that you were collecting for the
base camp so people your travel apart
all dying and stuff at that and it's got
X pain and level up and all that good
stuff so it's just a fun way of running
Just Dance 2016 it's probably the best
sort of dancing game out there there's a
few but this has probably been my
favorite one for our all the ones i've
played now just on 26 it hasn't really
changed the formula that much dancing
it's good time so you can have up to six
people at the same time buying it you
link your smartphone to the game and you
can all do cool moves and stuff for that
and you look stupid but as if you
involves drinks having a good time but
then this is Fitness so low calorie
drinks low calorie drinks just remember
that
xbox fitness it's if you've got an xbox
one you've already got xbox fitness as
long as you've got the gold membership
stuff which everyone pretty much does
that's how you play online and watch
things everybody welcome with a mother
of all X workouts ridiculous i can't do
extreme fitness but the cleanest fitness
it's quite good you've got a personal
trainer on screen telling you everything
to do they connect tracks or your
muscles and stuff like that because it's
a it's a crazy piece of hit but you can
see yourself representing it as like I
sort of skeleton with muscles and stuff
on the screen moving around it will pop
up things on screen saying like oh your
friend did it at like this time Rio he
did it way quicker than you so you
should maybe speed up you know I I want
to beat my friend day he sucks i'll run
a little harder and stuff like that so
it's fun kind of let's see it on three
you know what to say one two three you
probably think in Guitar Hero live
that's clearly nothing to do with
fitness you look like a man who's got
nothing to do a fitness you've tried to
sneak in again that's got nothing to do
a fitness but you would be wrong this
might sound familiar
guitar hero live if you don't play it
like I do which is just sort of sitting
down well I do that like i just sit
which isn't the way you should do it in
this example you stand up you move
around have fun with friends do it to
play your jumping around all that stuff
so there you go playing a tiny little
plastic pretend guitar and you're losing
weight bonus yes one weave a screamer
all right it's me done take a look at
Sky News on mobile and ipad for some
bonus features from this week's episode
including a closer look at some of those
fitness trackers from Angela's report
you go next week bye bye